Пам'ятаєте, як добре Німеччина справлялася з пандемією на самому її початку?
Що ж - це вже історія! З настанням другої ковідної зими ситуація в Німеччині стрімко погіршилась.
Нині все дещо складно.
Тож виникає запитання: чому Німеччина не може уникнути четвертої хвилі?
По-перше, згадаймо: перший випадок зараження коронавірусом у Німеччині виявили у січні минулого року.
Майже одразу команда науковців під керівництвом найвідомішого німецького вірусолога Крістіана Дростена
розробила ПЛР-тест для виявлення інфекції.
На це їм знадобилося лише два тижні.
А вже в листопаді минулого року німецька компанія BioNTech разом із американською Pfizer
розробила першу вакцину, схвалену ВООЗ для використання в усьому світі.
Через кілька тижня цією вакциною вже щеплювали у США і Великобританії.
Проте в Німеччині, країні, де розробили вакцину, це почалося пізніше.
Врешті і тести, і вакцина стали доступними у ФРН на початку цього року.
Тож німцям вдалося створити найкращі умови для подолання ковіду.
Але чому тоді не вдалося уникнути четвертої хвилі?
Спершу більшість німців відчайдушно намагалися зробити щеплення,
сподівалися подолати пандемію і тиснули на уряд, щоб це сталося якнайшвидше.
Але кампанія з вакцинації почалася повільно.
ФРН замовляла вакцини разом з іншими країнами ЄС.
Ось чому в Німеччині вакцинація стартувала пізніше, ніж, наприклад, у США.
ЄС недооцінив попит. Виробничі потужності були обмежені. Вакцин виробили недостатньо, тому спершу було занадто мало доз.
Але навіть після того, як поставки налагодили, отримати свій укол все одно було непросто.
Запис на щеплення був хаотичним.
Гарячі лінії не справлялися із кількістю дзвінків, а цифровізація, яку помалу запускали в Німеччині, мало цьому допомогла.
Запрошення надходили листом і більшість даних пацієнтів лікарям доводилося записувати вручну.
Іноді люди чекати на вакцину годинами або вирушали за нею далеко від дому в один із центрів вакцинації.
Але замість того, щоб прагматично вакцинувати людей прямо там, де вони живуть,
у Німеччині довгий час щеплення організовували за занадто складними схемами.
Після такого жорсткого старту кампанія вакцинації все таки помалу запустилася. І здавалося, що все працює… до літа цього року.
Влітку рівень захворюваності суттєво впав, оскільки люди більше часу проводили на вулиці, а не в приміщеннях, де ризик підхопити вірус - вищий.
Але як тільки загроза, здавалося, відступила, все більше німців почали не з'являтися на вакцинацію.
Експерти постійно наголошували: зважаючи на дуже заразний варіант вірусу дельта
тільки вакцинація на рівні 80-85 відсотків може врятувати від четвертої хвилі коронавірусу.
Попри попередження медиків і вчених, нині вакцинувалися лише близько 69 відсотків жителів Німеччини.
На це є різні причини. За даними дослідження, майже половина невакцинованих не хочуть цього робити,
бо їх змушують до цього або вони не довіряють вакцині.
І це попри перевірені факти і наукові дослідження про ефективність вакцини і малий ризик довгострокових побічних ефектів.
Хоча більшість німців позитивно ставлять до вакцинації, все одно є невелика група скептиків та антивакцинаторів.
Деякі з них поширюють теорії змови про те, що вакцина - це частина зловмисного плану, розробленого урядом і таємними елітами.
Праворадикали регулярно використовували протести проти обмежувальних заходів
для поширення своєї антидемократичної програми і підбурювання інших.
Німецькі політики неохоче ставляться до обов'язкової вакцинації.
Але уряди інших європейських країн більш активні, коли йдеться про заохочення до вакцинації і створення стимулів для людей.
Франція та Італія одними з перших запровадили паспорт вакцинації, без якого неможливо зайти в ресторан, кінотеатр та інші місця.
І на відміну від Німеччини вони суворо контролювали це навіть влітку, коли інфікованих було менше, а люди більше часу проводили на вулиці.
Німеччина починає робити це тільки зараз.
Є ще одна відмінність від інших країн.
До кінця листопада німецькі політики ухилялися від будь-яких заходів, які могли б тиснути на невакцинованих:
чи то суворіші правила, чи то обов'язкова вакцинація.
Але через стрімке поширення вірусу політики вже розглядають відповідні заходи.
Зокрема, обмеження контактів для невакцинованих, скорочення кількості людей на масових заходах.
Також обговорюється й обов’язковість вакцинації.
Чому на це так довго наважувалися? Одна з багатьох причин - нинішні політичні зміни в Німеччині.
Анґела Меркель йде з посади канцлера через 16 років при владі.
Тож до вересневих виборів країна була повністю занурена в передвиборчу кампанію.
Вірусу все одно, чи перебуває Німеччина нині у перехідному періоді з тимчасовим урядом, який я очолюю,
чи відбуваються переговори щодо формування нового уряду.
Під час передвиборчої кампанії політики не хотіли зробити себе непопулярними, обіцяючи суворі заходи, що обмежують життя людей.
Тож уряд Меркель в останні місяці свого правління багато делегував федеральним землям.
Після виборів Німеччина теж перебуває в перехідній фазі, коли формується новий уряд.
А це також означає, що немає чіткої політичної волі і людини, яка задавала б тон, запроваджуючи суворі заходи для стримування вірусу.
А це терміново потрібно.
Оскільки в Німеччині все ще мільйони людей невакциновані, багато хто з серйозними ускладненнями потрапляє у переповнені реанімації.
Захист, який надають нинішні вакцини, ослабне через кілька місяців і вакциновані можуть знову заразитися і передавати вірус іншим.
Допомогла б бустерна вакцинація, але Німеччина і тут занадто повільна.
До кінця листопада бустерну дозу отримали 9 мільйонів людей - це лише кожен десятий німець.
Усе це призвело до того, що Німеччина не змогла уникнути четвертої хвилі.
А через недавно виявлений варіант вірусу омікрон постають нові виклики.
І, на жаль, весь тягар знову мають прийняти на себе медики:
відділення інтенсивної терапії дуже швидко заповнюються, медсестри виконують свою роботу на межі сил.
Незважаючи на їхні зусилля, прямо зараз в Німеччині щодня помирають сотні людей. Тож прогнози вчених драматичні.
Новий уряд розпочинає свою роботу в грудні.
Його перше завдання - повернути Німеччину в потрібне русло, і дуже важливо, щоб це у них вийшло правильно.
У будь-якому випадку, зима легкою не буде.